so um things are things are still
happening as far as matt gates and the
possible sex trafficking allegations uh
article from the associated press
uh about joel greenberg joel greenberg
is the friend of matt gates who pleaded
guilty earlier this year to sex
trafficking
he is asking a judge
to postpone sentencing until next year
so he can keep coordinating with federal
authorities now our layperson's
understanding of this from the outside
is that joel greenberg's cooperation
goes specifically to the substance of
what matt gates did and what matt gates
was involved with that's the belief that
the idea of some kind of co-conspiracy
involving these individuals i'm using
that term colloquially not in the legal
sense so joel greenberg says give me
more time i'm going to keep giving
investigators stuff
which we believe might eventually be
used to charge matt gates greenberg
asked to move the sentencing to next
march
this will give the former local tax
collector
from orlando more time to be interviewed
by federal investigators according to
the court filing
which said the extension was unopposed
by prosecutors meaning they're probably
getting pretty good stuff
quote indeed mr greenberg's ongoing
cooperation which will not be completed
prior to his current sentencing date
could have an impact on his final
sentence he wants a lower sentence by
continuing to give them dirt greenberg
is facing up to 12 years in prison after
pleading guilty at last may to six
federal crimes
including sex trafficking of a child
identity theft stalking wire fraud and
conspiracy to bribe a public official
gates was not mentioned in the plea
agreement but greenberg's cooperation
could play a role in an ongoing
investigation into whether gates paid a
17 year old girl for sex so let's now go
to some clips of matt gates
matt gates appeared on abc 3 i believe
this is down in florida
and
he
is asked about whether he's concerned
about uh what's going on with joel
greenberg and he says that he's not he's
more concerned about socialism are you
worried that you're going to be charged
based on joel greenberg's actions and
your associations with him and your
actions with him i'm not i'm way more
concerned about the socialism engulfing
our nation than the scandals sex
trafficking no we're becoming socialist
what seems to be engulfing the media i'm
glad that people are able to view these
anonymous baseless allegations against
me through the lens of the extortion
effort that steve alford was a part of
that other people were a part of are you
worried and that by the way if you're if
you're hearing that and saying what on
earth is that about
uh gates and i i believe maybe even his
dad is somehow tied into this
they're claiming they're being extorted
or that gates dad was being extorted or
something like that
then asked more about joel greenberg
and gates basically
seems to throw him under the bus and
says he regrets ever having been
associated with joel greenberg here i
believe there may have been a time where
greenberg swung by the office but it
certainly didn't have anything to do
with uh any bad acts on my part no you
guys still friends or i'm assuming the
answer is no no when when uh when i
became aware uh of
some of greenberg's misdeeds i deeply
regretted my friendship with him and and
misdeeds in which gates is believed to
be involved that note i want to speak to
my constituents go ahead because i do
believe that it's fair for the people of
northwest florida to judge me based on
the associations that i've had and i
deeply regret my association with joel
greenberg politically socially and
otherwise but when folks evaluate that i
hope they evaluate it alongside the good
work that i've done yeah unfortunately
the other stuff he's done is also
terrible now in florida they may not
think that he's from a conservative part
of florida or represents a conservative
part of florida they may not see it that
way
but
we still
reasonably think
matt gates could end up charged with
some pretty serious crimes and i told
you was it last week or was it monday
must have been last week maybe it was
three years ago i don't know time's
weird these days no i think it was last
week that gates has hired a who's who
roster of lawyers who specialize in
defending against sex crimes now he's
entitled to do that everybody's entitled
to a defense he's innocent until proven
guilty hasn't even been charged yet
you tend to get lawyers expert in the
subject relevant to your interactions
with the law and so the fact that he's
hiring experts in defending sex crimes
certainly points to the probability or
possibility i guess better said that
such crimes uh may be what he is
ultimately charged with we're going to
follow it hopefully sooner than later
we'll know where this is going one of
our sponsors is blinkist who's been
supporting the david pakman show longer
than any other sponsor blinkist is the
app that lets you listen to or read an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below